hello and welcome sorry to this video
and sorry ah so what we got here again
mr. bones yeah let's try to play better
this time I really got totally killed in
the game before that uh-huh we get it
Ben Oni here ok I'm going to decline
this and play more classical kind of
position see what we get here I think
that white has slant has chances for a
slight edge here actually so bit like a
nympho a tempo up I mean it's not
nothing particularly threatening but it
feels like white should be quite
comfortable here so let's see a three
years a move maybe go for a three before
that is an idea also in the names oh but
with the tempo up it makes quite some
sense now why just trying to block the
isolated pawn hmm ok very early a for
him
ok I probably have to take
hmm yeah normally why this just taking
this night in many other situations of
that type but no not after a four I
think that doesn't make an awful lot of
sense yeah I'm just trying to play
against this isolated pawn should see
that I move the Queen out of the pin
that black seems to be ok M nothing
terrible happening to her hmm
oh i can i can trade on e4 and play 95
hmm well maybe this is a little bit that
seems a bit like a very simple kind of
solution I just wonder if I may be still
have an edge because the people I
Swedish mmm maybe this is too too simple
a play I know what I didn't really
appreciate that he has d1 under control
so I don't have looked he won that was
my idea actually to pay a quick rookie
one huh that's that's unfortunate
unfortunate somewhat just a misjudgment
yeah yeah I was thinking about this but
with this okay can take a 5-4 complete
equality maybe you will do that no hmm
ok
I feel hideous to still prove that it is
equal now it is actually very equal okay
nothing much that he has to prove okay
and that's important okay maybe I can
still try a little bit here a king to g3
myates its draw it's a draw he has to
make a couple of mistakes to get this to
something that is remotely interesting
yeah i think as if he comes over to c7 i
have to worry about my rook there so i
probably have to have to go with this
draw offered and not not just yet i mean
i'm pretty sure i kill k can go king of
seven and let me let it let me has to go
king of seven and then it's okay i can i
can actually go up there chad just want
to check that quickly but he can go look
22 here for the draw i roped it to as a
des dad okay that's also pretty much dad
therefore that's a draw draw offered
game draw yeah there was a bit not too
ambitious I didn't play that ambitious
enough ambitiously enough but it was
just a pretty simple mistake the hours I
wasn't seeing that I can actually this
is actually good I have to take on c6
now huh I didn't think about that at all
this and here 95 is annoying hmm now it
is like here here and here wow wow okay
now I didn't see that at all I had a
very a really bad um yeah I don't know
hallucination or whatever you recall it
I was really thinking I can't get to do
one quickly here but this is this is
just just wrong and Bishop d7 does
equalized I mean here i was thinking i
can do something against the B porn but
there is nothing serious going on him
maybe I shreeji for but I think it's in
sedro anyway I'm surprised that the
engine is giving me such a huge
advantage I was thinking that I have to
go with the a pawn up in this hmm yeah
that's actually true that's actually
true this is what I should have tried
this is still pretty pretty nice
advantage interesting
I was a little bit afraid that once the
King comes here and i have to go 85 then
my point is dropping which might be true
but in the meantime I'm mopping up the
Kings side bad technical play there
still was something here after the
desert that is dead it's dead I didn't
play that well chak tok can try g4
that's given by the engine but that's
also draw something like that is going
to be a drawing yeah yeah yeahs are not
very exciting but I sure I didn't play
that play that well now the technical
part of this game okay well thanks for
watching